[Music]
in fruit sabotage news oh damn okay
mm-hmm submitted by got my first chin
hair are you a woman
I'll be lucky maybe she went through
puberty that's like a sign of puberty
the chick yeah
I don't know where anyone wants to in
here if it's just one old Chinese guys
do on a ball yeah you want chin hair on
there mold or grow out cuz it means good
luck honey damn you never it never
shaved it [ __ ] disgusting yeah you
ain't getting no [ __ ] with that more
hair the game Chinese [ __ ] because
they're like ooh that Chinese man looked
yeah but doesn't gonna get a woman with
[ __ ] calluses on her knuckle from
scrubbing on a washboard all day woman
what the [ __ ] many grandma afro and
buff shoulders why not they probably
give good massages she can go for hours
with those washboard knuckles cuz I've
seen my grandma's hands and she has like
baseball mitts and if she jacked me off
you would not listen you don't complain
Rose did you say she jacked Pete yeah if
you guys put me in that hypothetical
situation know the mittens
yeah think about the men just [ __ ]
dick he just glazed over he was like
yeah my grandma jerked me off that would
be horrible anyways tip what's the
article got a flexible mine Australia is
in the midst of a fruit contamination
scare after needles are found in
strawberries needles needle like that
like what they do with Halloween candy
or what they claim that happens the
Halloween is it naturally-occurring
needles like obviously not like the
needles poking it in there Oh
oh my that would that's [ __ ] up
they're putting them in wrong because
they're putting it from the top like
into the green and when I bite into a
strawberry I bite into it this way you
know Oh somebody somebody holds the
strawberry like if this was a strawberry
and then this was the green
they're holding somebody holds it like
this but not really went to the hospital
because they swallowed what are they
doing are they putting dipping those
needles in AIDS
what no well not that I know cuz this is
not dangerous enough for you you want it
to like up the ante a little bit like
she's mine already trying to spread aids
and [ __ ] like you ever heard about
people poking people with AIDS needles I
have yeah but I don't think you need a
needle to spread eight you just need the
blood and then for it to enter your yeah
but it's hard to put my blood on you
it's easier if eyes if I got AIDS I just
dab my aids and I put it in like a grape
and you eat it you know what I mean yeah
right mewed me the needle for that it's
easier no well yeah so this is happening
in Australia and there have been over 20
reports strawberries before I eat it man
[ __ ] him all the time cuz it take a
thank you tacky you're saving my life
even though we're not did you catch any
needles in there oh we're not in
Australia but I'm just saying he could
come over here yeah so this is the oh
and they've also recently found one in
an apple and a banana this person's got
a lot of time inpatient now it's been
working with very small tools it's been
linked to three strawberry factories so
these fractal worker they're well
they're coast raw berries that are being
affected are coming from those factories
so we don't know if it's like in the
grocery store that are receiving those
shipment
I vote for grocery store I think so it
all over like all over the country oh
wow epidemic addition warehouse Oh
yeah it's pretty crazy it's from its
from all it's from a distribution
produce warehouse or they could just be
going in different locations to because
they say so this reminds me of a story
for a story back in Texas in the 90s
they found this group of people like
across like four different cities that
were getting sick two of them died and
they were getting like deathly sick and
so the police are like what is going on
and they were all dying of the same
thing coming to find out and this was
before they put the sealed caps on
medicine and somebody was taking
capsules and filling them with cyanide
and then putting the pills back on the
shelves it's not a pharmaceutical
platter when they were going into a
grocery store and doing it yeah they
were going into different grocery stores
and doing it so like there's like sick
people out there that will do it and
they will travel just to like spread it
out and it's like see what happens
so recently there has been a report that
a young boy I don't know the age there's
no name but that this young boy has been
taken in linked to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is like an Easter egg hunt [ __ ]
gone bad except it's the worst he's
regular at least we're not putting
needles and tampons works level cuz I
don't look at that [ __ ] is a certain
dose but yeah open that thing nope I
always do the check and bang you're not
really looking at yeah oh yeah it's in
the applicator you got to open it and
then got this and put it back in the
applicator but then but then how it
would be inside the tire has to be
inside a tampon right
stop giving people ideas that was a
great idea Morgan coming that's the word
you know what tampons work I just
thought you just put it you put it in
and then you like that what's an extreme
like that with cotton boom I mean
however like your sizes no you're
supposed to like predict your period a
day in advance and you swallow it and
then it just plugs a button that would
be crazy
do you think that the Dove killed
yourself
what so what's what they don't have any
leads or anything just telling everybody
be careful everybody don't eat the
strawberries don't eat it's like chop
came to your fruit first and no princess
there are a lot of copycats that are
making the investigation harder so other
people are started join us yeah I I
don't know I guess fruits yeah [ __ ]
good don't see that but then like
they're also they'll also be putting
their own needles in the fruit and then
taking a photo and putting it on social
media to look I can make fun of it or to
pretend like they're a victim too and
they're just making it harder oh god
that's so scary look why don't people
gotta ruin the simple things it's a
strawberry you know I bet you it's a
junk food conspiracy
[Music]
people mystery dolls on the healthy food
I mean the food industry they've already
or at least four strawberry farms
they've had one of the worst season in
recent years and oh my god what if this
is a marketing ploy to get rid of
strawberries no just like to just like
rip I was a joke just like boost like
any publicity is good publicity is a big
horse yeah no one's buying strawberries
now actually been having the dump all
the strawberries because of like there's
a good marketing ploy is it worse if you
need a marketing ploy for fruits you
just gotta make them dick shake any dick
shaped fruits you sell them at the super
morning these people fly off the shelf
oh this great never buy my children your
cake shaped a whole strawberry section
and just all dick shape strawberries you
wouldn't buy those not for my kids I
probably bought for you guys exactly
dude fly off the shelves they would ya
yes they would but I'm saying you if if
you if you're a fruit person like a
fruit factory and man a dick purse and
you're not selling enough fruits make
them dick shape and I guarantee they'll
fly off the shelf picture if you do it
after all the markets in San Francisco
you would the media on the sell out I
think you got a patent I did just Google
penis shaped pasta the other day so
you're not entirely wrong
it exists like penis mm-hmm yeah
everything if you go to what that
[ __ ] Spencer or ours at the mall they
have a whole section that's just
everything's penis you get a [ __ ]
cake mold you get a cookie mold it's
just there at the store you could see
everything it's a lot of sex stuff yeah
yeah yeah it's like for like
bachelorette parties and [ __ ] you want
to do like a have you ever met a woman
that like you think would have a penis
themed bachelorette party yeah
picture of you one of my friends had
that and I was just like oh that's
interesting that you'd be into it it's
actually the more concern yet usually
it's the more conservative you are the
more conservative you are the more your
friends they didn't want to push her
buttons to make you squirm you're super
like she was like this biochemist like
super square didn't plan it
oh but she loved it what is she like all
about it of Honor plans or whatever so
it's always like you know when you help
your friend like if you already have a
friend at the [ __ ] when you go to the
strip club you don't really care about
buying them a lap dance Jordan you're
[ __ ] comfortable with this [ __ ] who's
a [ __ ] virgin here or who's the
person I get anyone to buy dance that's
why I go and do I don't get a lap dance
I just buy everybody else one could it's
funny lap dance
mm-hmm and we got yeah it's funny to
watch them enjoy it all secret freaks
yeah they are yeah they are the
biochemist oh for sure yeah she's Balkan
so the lesson in the moral of the story
is look for conservative people to have
wild sex with Oh look like [ __ ] they're
gonna be boring always wanted the
librarians yeah that's the most like
yeah like square person out there the
librarians the ones out here watching
that porn that's got less than 50,000
views you know that that's how you know
that's gonna be like not all like
[ __ ] stuffed animals and [ __ ]
shouldn't press a button and the [ __ ]
buckles over it is like a sex dungeon
secret lies like ants on the wall yeah I
don't even know what a woman would do I
don't know like a strap-on [ __ ]
interesting a giant latex ass that was
my idea of a second know you're married
stuff but I've never been like oh we're
gonna be latex ass ass wouldn't smell
very good
oh you smell funky
yeah well Costas you had as you lost a
silicon yes that's what I actually meant
I used the wrong material it's like
jello a latex one would be like like
that bondage just like a black
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]